plus de 300 supporters autour du terrain
les sponsors sur les maillots le parfum
de la coupe de france flotter ce
dimanche 17 octobre sur chambourcy les
pensionnaires de 3e division de district
recevait le red star club de national
pour une rencontre de gala les espoirs
de qualification se sont envolés
rapidement au bout de 20 secondes de jeu
les visiteurs ouvrent la marque 1 à 0
les huit divisions d'écart se font
ressentir les joueurs d'habib beye
accélère pour marquer deux puis trois
puis quatre puis cinq buts en première
période 5 à 0 à la mi temps je pense
qu'on était un peu stressé on s'est pris
un but au bout de 30 secondes de jeu
après on s'est un petit peu libéré mais
bon on a fait une première période
stressé j'ai envie de dire sur les dix
premières minutes on est con on reste
quand même dans le match mais après
c'est la différence de niveau tout
simplement ça va beaucoup plus vite et
beaucoup plus propre il ya très peu de
déchets donc le résultat est normal j'ai
envie de dire en deuxième période
remobilisés à la pause par leur
entraîneur les yvelinois tiennent tête
aux pensionnaires de national il
encaisse seulement un but en 45 minutes
le match se termine sur le score de 6 à
0 pour les visiteurs c'est une belle
victoire tout important c'est qu'on
puisse avoir une fête ici à chambourcy
j'avais échangé avec médias avant le
match l'entraîneur de chambourcy donc
voilà je pense que la fête a eu lieu les
gens sont contents d'avoir vu un bon
match de football franchement belle fête
super match c'était vraiment quelque
chose d'incroyable d'extraordinaire on a
tout ce qui fait je pense malgré le
score malgré la défaite mais au-delà de
ça franchement c'était vraiment
vraiment incroyable malgré la défaite ce
5e tour restera le plus beau parcours en
coupe de france de l'histoire du club de
chambourcy une belle épopée selon les
spectateurs venus assister au match
parmi eux des anciennes gloires du paris
saint germain cette équipe de chambourcy
a montré des belles valeurs les valeurs
de la région et un bon s'incliner contre
le red star qui est une équipe de
national je pense que c'est c'est
enrichissant une expérience
enrichissante qui pourrait servir au
club dans les prochaines semaines dans
le championnat de 3e division de
district les joueurs ont désormais un
objectif en tête une montée en fin de
saison
[Applaudissements]